[ Music ]
[ Silence ]
>> How do you empower the
constituencies you serve
and create a healthier community
through the work
that you do each day?
So how do you empower
your constituencies
and create a healthier community
through the work that you do?
And I'll start again with
Dartanian [assumed spelling].
>> All right.
So, at NCLR our mission is to
improve the education health
and well-being of
youth in communities
of color specifically
by empowering them
to enact social change,
through research training
and community mobilization.
We focus on what's
called health equity.
For us, health equity is
about closing disparities
and closing the gap between
those who do have access
to resources and
those who do not.
We believe that all
community should have access
to fresh whole foods, to a clean
and safe open spaces as well
as quality medical care.
In our work we're committed to
helping people build capacity
so they can make sort of
choices in their lives base
on the opportunities that
are available that are
in their own best interest.
We define food justice
as communities exercising
their right to grow,
sell and eat healthy food
that is fresh, nutritious,
affordable, culturally
appropriate, grown locally,
with care for the land, for
the people and the animals.
And so one of the
ways that we work
to empower our community members
and our residents is first
by listening to them, so
part of our core values is
to privilege their
voice and to ensure
that the things we do are the
things they want to do, right?
So we bring-- We're able to
bring skills and resources
to the table but at no point do
we go to folk in our community
and the community that I'm from
and tell them this is
what they need to do.
What we also work to do
is develop social justice
youth leaders.
And so we have a
curriculum for our young folk
where they participate
throughout the entire year
in classes that are actually
located in their schools
where they learn about social
justice issues that are relevant
to them and then they're also
would become critical youth
researchers who go
out and teach others
about what they both
discover but conduct research
in the community so they
can tell their own story.
So it's important for us to not
speak for people but to ensure
that they can speak
for themselves.
And then we also have a summer
youth fellowship program called
the Urban Health
Fellows where we work
with African American
Latino males
to help them become peer
advocates where they go
into the community, they not
only conduct this research
that I mentioned earlier
but they teach their peers
about the challenges they are
facing about their rising--
raise of diet related
diseases in Englewood.
Roughly 47.8% of our
students are classified
as either being obese
or overweight
and that's a significant
challenge.
When we expect it by
2020 that every one
in two African-Americans
and close to one
in two Latino students or
youth will have diabetes,
that's a problem in our
communities and I think one
of the strategies
that we've been able
to utilize is having our young
folk actually lead the charge.
Have them talk to their
peers, talk to their parents.
We also have what's called
healthy lifestyle centers
where our community members are
able to participate in health
and nutrition courses in
classes, they learn how
to grow their own
food, they learn how
to plant fruit trees we've
distributed 4600 fruit trees
creating more fruit
assets in our community.
We've also been able to plant
400 shade trees addressing urban
heat island affect in
our community as well
and have people have spaces to
come together and community both
through these healthy
life style centers
and the gardens that
we're building.
And so for us it's
combination of a few things.
It's making sure the people
have access to skills and access
to resources but
it's also assuring
that their voice is
prioritized in the process
and then providing the
support that's necessary
to enact change within
the community.
So it's fundamentally
about lifting up people
in our community so
that they can live.
>> So I think that's
probably the reason why Dart
and I are both on the
leadership boarder that I
like to call it the council.
The work that he and social
justice learning is doing
in Englewood is very so much to
our sort of philosophy interior
of social change, right?
So, we believe at the future
working alliance that those
who are marginalized, those
who are facing the problems
and issues in their communities,
in their workplace
should be the ones
in the leadership developing
the solutions to those problems
and organizing, right,
to make those changes.
And so the work that we do
is really supporting the work
of our member organizations.
We have 23 member who
works around the country,
some are representing farm
workers, others are organizing
with food, I mean culture
process team workers,
warehouse workers, grocery
workers, restaurant workers,
street vendors all
throughout the chain.
And so we support their
organizing campaigns, right?
Through organizing campaigns,
these workers are making changes
in their communities, in
their workplaces, you know,
winning raises in the minimum
wage, higher living wages
in their workplaces and we
also support the leadership
development of these workers.
So we have an annual
worker leaders and retreat
where we bring together
these worker leaders
from our different
member organizations
and they share their
experiences,
they share their stories,
they got to know each other
and really build this
movement of food worker, right,
because you need to
develop those relationships
to build a movement.
And so at those retreats
we also invite folks
to share their skills,
need workshops,
learn how to tell
their stories somewhere
to what you were talking about
Dart, right, to be able to speak
up for themselves and to talk
about what are the solutions
that they want to work towards
and then work in the lines
through to support that.
So they are part of planning
for what we do in the line.
Our retreat last year,
they came up with this idea
of a new training program
so that they can learn more
in depth about what are the
issue facing all the workers
throughout the food
system and not just workers
in their own sector, and
also what is this food
justice movement?
How can they get connected?
What are the other issues
that they've been still face
but maybe haven't
made the connections
yet to their issues as workers?
And so we're going
to be starting a pilot
program this year.
In addition, they want to
learn about the history
of the food system, how we
got into where we are today
and how has raised in
labor in class, you know,
gender issues all played into
why we have this current,
you know, corporate industrial
food system that's exploding
workers in the environment,
in our communities
and then how can we
organize to turn that around,
so that's the whole
bit that folk can do.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> So, in our area we work
more with parents and family.
In their family some
we basically work a lot
with the mothers.
[ Foreign Language ]
So we basically try to work
with them in issues related
to housing not only to issues
in the field and we also try
to educate them that because
they don't speak the language
they don't have right.
They have rights
to a descent job,
they have rights to housing.
[ Foreign Language ]
We are several census,
we're coworkers
who are promoters have direct
contact with the families.
[ Foreign Language ]
So we basically talk about
the bound nutrition, you know,
and that we also
talk about obesity,
diabetes which are issues very
common in our Latin community,
so we try to educate
them around those issues.
[ Foreign Language ]
So we'd also try to educate them
about how to cook, you know,
food that are typical
of our communities
which are really healthy
and even though sometimes we
cannot get the right products
or the ingredients but that
we can still cook healthy.
[ Foreign Language ]
So this is mainly what
we try to make them see
and also we give
them information
about where they can find
some produce that is typical
of their-- our traditional food
so that they can have
a better nutrition.
[ Foreign Language ]
So we also try to work with the
mothers and make them understand
that sometimes in this
country there are laws
that are very different from
the laws in our community.
Sometimes we have to learn how
to respect those laws and also
to use them for our
wellness and well-being.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> So, I think the question
is really a great question
and that I won't speak about
how we're directly affecting the
change but how we're influencing
the change and what we believe
in and what we're doing
as an organization right
now to engage community.
This past winter and
the spring, the--
our organization and the
Center for Community Engagement
at CSUCI, California State
University Channel Islands,
together with the health
communications course has been
working in a project that's
known as [foreign language],
that means Restoring
our Traditional Diet
to Create Greater Health.
We began by asking
community, first of all,
one quest-- two questions.
[ Foreign Language ]
What is that that you used
to eat in your community?
And when we're speaking
about community its
community back home
in Oaxaca, your homeland.
[ Foreign Language ]
How did your diet
change while being here?
And we asked these
questions in order
to really remember the value
of our diets and what it has
to influence in community
and how can you conserve
these traditions
and where did they come from?
And so that we can conserve
them, continue to conserve them
so we can continue to
teach it to our children
and their children
to their children.
We can now put a couple of
recipe examples just to throw
out a little bit of
what this context means.
So there is a couple of
things that I've note,
there's for example a recipe
could be [foreign language]
or [foreign language] or
[foreign language], they're kind
of like asparagus with some
sarsa and [foreign language].
You see, in Oaxaca, their
diet really does consist
of [foreign language],
kind of like stir-fries,
and what is seasonally
available.
So, through those practices,
you're able to really reach
out to where nurtures you
through the abundance
of the time.
So, during the months of May
through October ,that's the time
when there's a lot of grains
and it's really growing
in the forest and really
abundant and there's a lot
of plants and grains and
herbs and there's plants
like [foreign language] and
the list goes on and on.
And this is-- for example
in the [foreign language],
there's a lot of access to
what's sustainable there.
It's already growing
in abundance everyday
through the forest and go
and you harvest the
crickets and the ants.
I've tried them and
they're delicious.
And anything like that and
you share it with community
and you share with your family.
I'm sure all of you care
about your own personal health
but I'm sure you
also have your family
and you also have a
community type so that--
so when we speak
about sustainability,
that's not only how
it's affecting community
but how it's affecting you
because everything
in interrelated.
And just to let you
know a little bit
about the indigenous community
of Oaxaca and Guerrero in Pueblo
and these Mexican
indigenous people.
And generally, they
are deeply rooted
in sustainable practices
already.
There's a great ancestral
wisdom, ancient wisdom
that goes back centuries.
And so when we really
take a look at that,
we're able to really practice
if we were really just use
as an example whereas in
social inspiration we'd be able
to create greater
sustainable practices.
And so-- But unfortunately
as we know that's vastly
disappearing due to NAFTA,
the North American Free Trade
Agreement as we all know.
Farmers who used to sell, Eden
[assumed spelling] was talking
to me on the road I use
to go your own fruit
are no longer able
to complete with
big monoculture.
Farmers who come into the
territories, we have some
of the richest and most
biodiverse areas in the world.
And so, with that this
is creating a huge flock
in migration.
And so-- The flock is also
affecting ancestral lands
and tradition itself.
And so our community is shifting
their cultural practices
when they come to the US.
So, no longer are they able to
keep their tradition of ways
and living, they have to adjust
to new traditional-- new ways.
They have to navigate
unstable working environments.
They earn minimum wage
in order to survive.
At the same time
they're learning
to navigate the social
educational legal
and medical systems without the
help of their native language
and our organization we
really do all of our staff,
90% of our staff is indigenous
and speaks the native language
in order to support
that community.
So even though they're
working the very lands
that sustain everyone else,
it is not sustaining them.
And so the food that they
should be able to access,
accessible organic food
or traditional food is--
there isn't enough
growing spaces not even
in our backyards, little and
like the city and they earn less
than 15,000 and less
than 20,000 a year
so that means every week you're
having to spend around 150
to $250 a week just to earn--
just to buy food itself.
And most of it, from what
I learned is the food
that you harvested yourself,
you're not even able--
even able to buy that.
So it's very costly.
It affects as we
know every level.
And then the most sad
thing about this is that,
back in Oaxaca and
Guerrero and Pueblo,
these communities are constantly
being bombarded by Coca-cola
by [foreign language].
It's easier to go ahead and
get a couple of Coca-cola
or something than to get
access to clean water.
Or it's easier to get a bag
of [foreign language] you see
it here as would been known
as [foreign language],
some [foreign language] some
[foreign language], you know,
than to be able to grab fruits
and vegetables on the go.
So, I was recently in Sonora,
Mexico and there I was able
to go to the local market
and the local grocery stores
and guess what I saw, I saw
mountains and piles of pears
and fruits and vegetables
and they were all the ones
that were discarded from the
United States and sold their
for almost double the
price and they were bruised
and they were old and there's
a whole bunch of things in it
and most likely I'm sure
they're genetically modified,
and that's another
issue in itself.
But nearly, our question is
really how has really revolved
right now and how do we
restore traditional practices?
How do we bring that
indigenous wisdom back?
How do we bring it and so
that we value those ways
in our little enhanced
community?
And also we know that
we'll never going
to reach an idealized way of
living and eating and cooking
because those various
vegetables,
herbs are no longer accessible
here, they're being shipped.
When I get to be able to share
in a table with my colleagues
and I'm able to eat those
[foreign language] instead
of ants, they had to be
shipped up from Oaxaca
and that's the only
reason I'm able to do that.
But we're losing those bases.
And so what we learned
more recently is that we're
in the process of creating
a mystic cultural heritage
cookbook so that the families
we'd been able to serve
with the families, we've been
able to restore some of that
and there's a couple of
markets they can still find
these ingredients.
And just timewise, I just
want to say that we do have
to maintain continue
to save our seeds,
continue to teach our
young and continue
to gather wisdom
from our elders.
And the more we learn
about what sustain us,
the more we learn
about ourselves.
Thank you so much for your time.
>> So, before I talk about
what I do, I think I want
to talk a little bit
about why I do it.
Because intentions are
really, really important
in forming our passions and
continuing the work that we do.
And, specially as young
advocates and activist,
and making sure we
don't have burnout
because they continually
reminds you
of why you have those early
mornings and late nights.
So, as a Muslim, we have a
annual month, well obviously.
It's a month one out of a year
where we fast from dust to dawn.
And, since the Islamic
calendars are lunar calendar,
it changes throughout the year.
So, we fast from sometimes
3:30 am to 8 pm like this year
when the day was about 17,
16-- 16 or 17 hours long.
And you don't just do
that one day or two.
You do that for 30 days.
And, you stay away from food
and drink and you're supposed
to be the best version of
yourself that you can be.
And, it's kind of a
training opportunity for you
to really evaluate yourself
and why you do what you do
and just make yourself
a better person.
And during these days, oh man,
you really feel the hunger.
And the whole point of Ramadan
is so that you can empathize
with the people that
have less than yourself.
What I find as I grow older
and I'm part different
social circles is
that we spend all day
hungry and thirsty
and then we all get
together around the table
of extravagant food
and just feast
until we all have a food coma.
And that is totally beyond
and missing the point
of what Ramadan is
supposed to be about.
And, I didn't really understand
how intense hunger was
for people who actually
experience it on a day
to day basis until I
visited my home country
of Pakistan last year.
I had gone back after 18 years
and so it was a very
surreal experience for me.
And right now like, you know,
there are places in California
where hunger is very apparent.
And then, there are
places in California
where hunger is disguised.
When you go to a developing
country, it is very clear
who is hungry and who is not.
And I was able to see people
that were in my family
that lived in these beautiful
homes and then folks that--
and people that were also
part of my family that lived
in the most decrepit
and horrible housing
commissions that they could.
And what's worst than that is
you see people on the streets
who don't have arms
or eyes or legs
that are begging for
just food to eat.
And, I came back and
I've been thinking
about this experience
for the last year.
I've been thinking about
why I do the work I do
and how I can kind of help the
circle of people that I'm in.
And I know that as an
activist and as an advocate,
I can't change everybody's life.
Like, I'm very realistic about
the impact that I can make.
But, I think that if you
allows then this is some
to prevent this
from contributing any little
change that we can make.
Then, we really have missed our
opportunity for social change.
So, as a student region,
I decided that, you know,
hunger was a priority of mine.
You know, I come from
an immigrant family.
My father certainly was
incredibly poor in Pakistan.
And, my grandfather had to
travel very far distances
and move far away to be able
to work to support my family
and I am standing
it in front of you
because my father got this
one-in-a-million scholarship
to come to the United States.
And then, he moved
his family here.
So, I think about
poverty and hunger a lot
because if it weren't for that
scholarship, if it weren't
for one or two things
that happened in my life
or in my history then I would
have been one of those people
that not only has to fast
for 30 days out of the year
but 365 days out of the year.
And that is the reality for the
majority of the world out there.
So when I came back to
Berkley, I started thinking
about what I need to do.
And, you know, already the
food pantry was established
at that time.
And, we had students that
were solely growing in numbers
and coming and telling us that
they really appreciated the work
that Berkley was doing, that
they really needed food.
And, you know, I have to
say, it's one of the--
it's an interesting experience
when you have a peer come up
and tell you that they're
dealing with hunger issues.
Because, your first reaction is
just one of abhor and sadness
and just despair because
you just think what,
like I want to help you,
what can I do to help you
and what can I do to make sure
that you don't ever
go hungry again.
But it's also interestingly
empowering because you realize
that you are in this
position for a reason.
And that the work that
you do is not meaningless.
It really means a lot.
And even if you can make sure
that one more person is fed
through whatever effort
you can contribute,
you've done your job
as a human being.
So, I know that what
I have control
over is my current surroundings.
And as a student region,
I have access to resources
and administration and data.
And a number of people that,
sometimes don't realize
that hunger is a very prominent
thing college campuses.
When I talk to the
media about this,
they're completely horrified
like they literally are
speechless that students
at the UC in particular are
couch-surfing or showering
at the gym or living
out at their cars.
And what's even harder
about this is, is that
and you know this is actually
horrible but I'm going to come
out and say it like it's an
awkward conversation for folks
in power to have because
now it's not, you know,
the community that everyone
thinks is going hungry anymore.
Like it's not just, you know,
like the marginalized
communities of color
that are going hungry now.
Now it's an awkward conversation
for a lot of administrators
and a lot of people in power
because now it's
the middle class
that is also experiencing
this hunger.
And, I think that this
conversation is long
over due, right?
Like this has happening for so,
so long but we need to continue
to make sure that we are
addressing the structures
that can make this easy
for all of our students.
So, a big part of what we do is,
we sit down with financial aid,
we sit down with
dining services,
we sit down with student
affairs and we try
to learn what their
processes are like.
How do you give out aid?
How do you set your budget?
What is it that you already do
and how do we make
our process better?
So, give one good example,
I know my time is
kind of running out.
One of the examples is right
now there is a survey that goes
out every three years and
students report how much money
that they budget for food.
So, they'll say, "We spent
$10 a day, $15 a day,
whatever for our budget."
Now, this goes back to
the also the President
and then we distribute this
data back to the campuses.
The campuses average
these members
and then they set the food
budget for financial aid
and how much they're going
to package out to students.
Adversely, that number is $9
and 50 cents per day,
for the entire day.
That is nowhere nearer
being close to being able
to encompass an entire meal.
And so, what we're doing now
is working with the Office
of the President to see,
are we able to do some kind
of regional market analysis
to see what the actual
budget is like.
And, does that match up
with the current numbers
that we already have?
So, what I've learned
through all this is,
is that addressing hunger
is way beyond just providing
direct services.
It's actually addressing
the entire structure
that allows hunger
to even happen.
And, I hope and I pray
that, you know, 5 years,
10 years down the line that
we don't need to, you know,
have conversations about
folks that are going hungry,
that we don't need to express
how urgently we need food
pantries and emergency food
relief programs on our campus.
Because, ideally, we want
to eradicate hunger, right?
We want to eradicate hunger.
We want to heal malnourishment.
So, we're not there yet.
And so, these conversations
are really important
to continue having and I hope
that this somehow can serve
as a breading ground
for all those
inspirational conversations.
But that's a little bit of what
I do, why I do it and I'm hoping
that all of you will-- and
join me in this operation.
Thank you.
>> OK. And just before
Moses starts,
if you do have any
questions, please go ahead
and start passing up
those index cards.
Try not to walk in
front of the camera,
so walk around the outside
as you bring these up.
But please start bringing
these up as we hear
from our last panelist.
>> Sire.
>> Thank you, Melissa
[assumed spelling].
>> So, I want to tell you
a little bit more also
about why I do what I do.
And, it can't go without saying
that I'm Jewish-Colombian.
I was born in Columbia,
I was raised in Miami.
I was born to a woman who
is blonde and green-eyed.
And, everybody I knew up to
like 13 years old
was Jewish-Colombian.
So, that's kind of a
strange way to see the world
when you're a kid and you get
to the rest of world or you get
to California and you find
out you're white like,
that was a surprise
for me because here
in Santa Barbara we
have a lot of Hispanics
which are mostly Mexican.
And then, we have a
lot of white people.
And then, we have like the
0.01% of everybody else.
So, we have a lot of conversions
that are yet to have--
that we have yet to have.
But during this whole time,
the language that we have
in my family is about food.
Because if you know anything
about Jews and you know anything
about Colombians,
we like to eat.
That's for certain.
And so, but whenever we would
get together as a family,
whenever we'd be together,
the thing that I always talk
about would be environment.
And, my parents, through
that, they supported me
and they didn't really get it.
And then, as I study the
environment and I worked
with the Nature Conservative and
Environmental Defense Center,
the focus of these
organizations was actually
on agriculture and
on food policy.
And that really surprise me
because I thought we're going
to talk about climate
change and--
or not or just ecological
land preservation.
But as it turned out,
they're one in the same.
And so, even though my
background was an environment,
you can't do environmental work
without recognizing
the implications
of the agricultural system.
Along those lines,
a lot of people
in Santa Barbara especially,
we have these high hopes
for where the environmental
like the well-being
of our environment.
And at the same time we have so
many people living in poverty
that how are we going to
even have conversations
about recycling when
people haven't been fed.
And so, going back to Kathy's
[assumed spelling] question
about how do we empower
our community.
Above the Executive
Directors Office in--
at the Food Bank there is
three posters and they say,
"Nourish, Teach and Power".
But empowerment really
starts with the nourishment
because if anybody comes to
one of our food distributions,
they are welcomed with
a smile with dignity
and the opportunity
for education.
And that message and feeling is
present in every single person
at the Food Bank and in every
single one of our program.
And we want to give as
many resources as possible
but sometimes people
aren't ready to receive them
if they're still in
the nourish part.
And that's a conversation
that is hard sometimes to have
with foundations or with other
organizations when they're like,
go and do this, go and do that.
And it's like, well, they
are still working three jobs
and so we want them to come to
community meetings if they want
to and I'm working on that.
But sometimes we just need
to offer the food first
and I think empowerment starts
with building these
relationships
and understanding
what people are--
and meeting people
where they're at
and sometimes is just asking
them how their day was,
not asking them to
come to a rally.
>> Thank you all for those
wonderful pearls of wisdom.
So we'll go ahead to the
questions from the audience.
The first question
is for [inaudible]
and this is Oaxaca is the
state where the majority
of immigrants come
from the California.
How has this affected the
health of the immigrants,
their families both born in
Oaxaca and the US in regards
to the modernization of food?
Are they less healthy in the US
than they would be in Oaxaca?
>> I think this is a
good question for me
and my colleague in general.
We did a research study in
Oxnard, California that showed
that a lot of this
community is high in diabetes
and other cardiovascular
disease due to--
in Oaxaca there wasn't
really a use for oils
which is highly used now.
There's also greater access to
meats, fish, crab, all the meats
in general whereas there was
only access once in a while.
We have the money to buy the
meats, so there's a huge change
in that increase and it's--
we've been able to assess it
through the house
study basically.
So there is a huge
change and I think it's
because there was much
more access to fruits
and vegetables back
home than there is here.
And the fruits and vegetables
that are growing here,
if you want them to be
organic, they're like--
I don't know, it's
like $2, $3 per--
$6 for a packing of
blueberries, right,
that comes in this
little tiny ounces.
And how much that
the person get paid
to be able to harvest these?
You know, I know this because
they're my friends and they work
and they're not even
able to buy those berry--
blueberries that they-- that
we consider healthy, you know,
that are organic in
some way or another.
So it's directly affecting
their health everyday.
And then our children are also
being fed an American nice diet
at school.
So it's like hamburgers
and pizza and fries--
French fries and
they're no longer--
you know, when I was young and I
heard children really love pizza
and she traditionally
cooks a lot of her meals
in traditional ways and how
do you balance that out?
It's like my child is growing
up in this Americanized system
and like it's cool to go to Jack
in The Box or wherever it is
that kids want to go to
nowadays and not cool
to bring your lunch bill at
home with your traditional meal.
I remember being a
child and not wanting
to bring my burrito to school.
I wanted a [inaudible]
and I wanted an apple
with my little lunch box.
I want to be a normal
kid, right?
But no, it was-- so there
is a huge change in diet
and we can continue to talk
about what that looks like
and we'll follow the
conversation however that helps.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Sorry, wrong language.
So, basically as I
mentioned earlier, you know,
in Oaxaca we have access to
a lot of more organic foods.
We don't have access
to restaurants
to fast food restaurants,
so when we come here,
we also besides that access to
these type of a food, the mother
and the father have to work.
And so, you know, while in
Oaxaca only the father works.
The mother can have
more time to cook.
[ Foreign Language ]
So you get here and you see
that you can actually consume
meat and you see these.
Oh this is a change
which is great
but at the same time
it's not good.
[ Foreign Language ]
So because here it
is cheaper, you know,
you can get to hamburger
for $2 but a bag
of vegetable is more expensive.
[ Foreign Language ]
So, you know, also our working
schedule we work 10 hour,
12 hour days and so
we don't have time
to cook, so what do you do?
You drop by and buy $5
pizza on your way home
and that's what happens.
>> Thank you.
The next question is what
questions do you think need
to be ask to assess the
needs of university students
and local communities in regards
to food and food justice?
And that could go
to any panelists.
>> I feel like people
are looking at me.
[ Laughter ]
No, no. I'm totally not.
Like I said, I'm
totally new to this,
so definitely [inaudible]
his at on.
I think we just haven't even
asked the most basic questions,
right?
Like, you know, I think we
need to assess the demographic,
so what family you come from,
what your financial
bracket is roughly
so we can understand what
the demographic looks like.
But also we need to ask like
how much do you budget for food
or do you budget the food,
like have you taken, you know,
any kind of classes that
will help you budget.
Do you know how to read
the nutritional label,
like do you know where to go?
Do you know basic
things like, you know,
fun facts like if you
qualify for work study,
you also qualify for CalFresh.
People don't know these kinds
of things and so I think we need
to do a demographic
understanding
of who are our population is.
But also we need to ask
whether they know of a lot
of these resources are even
available and how as providers
or as advocates so we can do
a better job in advocating
for their need like
I think we need
to ask them what they need
first before we could kind
of practice strategy
on how do we address it
and that's also part
of the work.
The students are doing now
is trying to understand
like what did this--
what does it need to look
like for students so that we
can better develop our response.
>> Next question is what--
oh, [inaudible] first?
OK.
>> I just wanted to add, I
think it would also be important
to ask students what
are the values
that you want your
future reflect, right?
Do you want food that
is produced by workers
who are paid fairly a living
wage, do you want food
that is produced in
environmentally sustainable way,
food that is local or--
all those different
issues that we're tracking.
>> OK.
>> The next question is what US,
or California State policies
need to change in order
to support your goals for
the food system reform.
Dartanian, do you want to start?
>> Sure yeah.
So, you know, both
you and I serve
on the Los Angeles Food Policy
Council and I also serve
on the California
Food Policy Council
where there has been
this amazing movement
of youth leaders and
community leaders
who are advocating
very diligently
for change in our food system.
California-- I think is leading
the way in this disregard.
There were things that need
to happen in our communities,
for example, folk need to
ensure that rather we need
to have policies that
assure people have the right
to grow their own food.
You know, depending on where
you live it might not be illegal
actually for you to grow
food in your own home
or in your own backyard.
Now fortunately we
worked on AB2561 last year
which made it legal for tenants,
who live in single family homes
or in duplexes or at a
homeowners association
to grow food either on
a portable container
or in a small part of land.
Your landlord can't
stop you from doing that
but they can certainly tell
you where to put it, right?
But just think about
that for a second.
We're talking about food
sovereignty and sustainability
and the ability to care for your
family, to care for the land
and you don't even have
the right to grow food
in your own home,
that's a problem, right?
So I think it first starts with
acknowledging our sovereignty
and acknowledging the need
that we have to feed ourselves
so that we know our food
comes from, we can begin
to build connections again to
that food and then advocate
for the care of the land and
the people who are also growing
that food, so that's one
area that needs to change.
I think there are many
others that need to change.
Mainly what we-- how we
treat our farm workers
and the wages we pay people.
I mean, you know, I've
been saying this before,
I've said this recently and
I'll just say this again.
Much of what we're talking
about boils down to the economy
and economic and
equities that exist.
And so if we do things
like allow for record--
corporate profits to exist, but
then we also depression wages,
people are not going to be
able to care for themselves,
they're not going to be able to
purchase the food that they need
in order to eat healthy
and live healthy lives.
So we have to do things both in
our sort of food system as well
but we got to appreciate the
economic disparities that exist
which contribute to
these gaps that continue
to exacerbate diet
related diseases as well.
>> I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>> I super ask one of the main
policies that we have to hit
for is raising the
minimum wage, you know,
so I think Dart spoke
very eloquently
about the needs with that.
And for those of you
at UCLA you might know
that in Los Angeles now
there's the movement
to raise the minimum wage
there, I feel like LA is--
there's been study coming out.
Just yesterday I saw for
the typical [inaudible]
to actually afford
rent, they would need
to be paid $33 per hour.
And there's more people
living in apartment even in LA
than anywhere else
but you saw, you know,
just following the state minimum
wage we're just currently is $9
per hour.
So, yeah, so that's a very
important issue and we're also,
you know, we think they're
severe universal healthcare
for everyone, right, that
healthcare is the right
and that impacts
everyone's health
and the abilities will
also take care of itself.
So those are-- And the last
thing to add that, you know,
like farm workers aren't
outside of California
and Washington State actually
aren't covered by laws
that allow them the
right to organize
and to take collective action.
And even worker who
are protected
by that law it's very easy
for in court to fire them to,
you know, threaten them
and discipline them.
And so we think those
laws need to change too
to better protect workers and
insure all workers are protected
by that right to take
collective action
because that's really what's
going to build their, you know,
build democratic
workplaces in communities.
>> Wonderful.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> So earlier this year there
was an article published
by Mark Bittman and Ricardo
Salvado and I really wish
that Niki [assumed spelling]
from this morning would have
been an author on that paper
because we need more voices
on it especially women, but.
It was a call for
a national reform
to food policy in the farm bill.
And when you have a
farm bill that advocates
for a sick society like in
terms of wellness then help--
you can't have a healthy one, so
seeing these men come together
and ask the government and
just put it there, you know,
for the whole news media to say,
yes this is what
we're going for.
This is what we need.
These are the changes
that need to happen
and I applauded them
for doing that.
>> The next question
is as a child
of the Oaxacan immigrants
what advice would you give me
as to how to teach my
parents about sustainability
and that their ways in Oaxaca
are better than those here?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> So, basically what I'm doing
is trying to teach my daughters
about what I, you know, my life
and like during my childhood
in Oaxaca, how we ate,
how we actually ate directly
what we kind of State.
So for example I try to make a
salsa with tomatoes and chili
and maybe with an egg
that doesn't have fat.
[ Foreign Language ]
So as I mentioned before
in my work as a volunteer
at a community garden, I
teach them how to plant,
how to harvest and how you
can actually grow vegetables
without pesticides.
[ Foreign Language ]
So that's what I do as
part of my education.
I try them to-- get them
to eat more vegetables
and we all know children don't
like vegetables, you know,
but I try to make it a
point that we eat healthy.
>> Our next question is an
ongoing stigma with students
about being homeless,
couch-surfing,
receiving food stamps, and more.
What can be done to
reduce this stigma?
>> I think I can say
something about that.
So one of the things that the
Food Bank has done is we have
started to do food
distributions in the form
of healthy school pantries
which are like health fares.
And when someone arrives,
they go through this corridor
of services and it's welcoming
and it's generally services
that are needed by families.
But we talked with Hancock
[assumed spelling] recently
to see if that was a
model that would apply
to college level campus.
Different services, but
still more focused on health.
And as part of that,
they would receive food.
There would be some element
of food distribution,
but it wasn't just
that, that we're focused
on health and wellness.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Yeah, you know, I happen
to be one of those students
at the time when I
started undergrad at UCLA.
Coming from Los Angles
or South LA,
I didn't have access
to resources, right?
And I have a family
member I could pick
on the phone and call them.
In fact, because I was receiving
financially they would often
call me and say, "Hey
can you help us out?
We don't have anything to eat."
And so having been
in that situation,
I understand how
difficult it was.
I would work 30 to 40 hours
a week get in and out, right?
Sometimes that would be
my only meal for the day.
So I know how challenging
it can be as a student to go
through that and I think one of
the strategies that I was able
to utilize to both to get
support that I needed,
but to also be OK with that was
to approach my councilors,
right?
I had this amazing
councilor, two actually,
one was named Shelley Benton
and our academic supports
or academic services in the
College of Letters and Science
at UCLA who took the
time to get to know me,
to get to know my needs, and to
understand what those needs were
and provided advice
and direction.
The other person was
my [inaudible] mentors
in the academic advancement
program
at UCLA who did the same.
So it's by building
relationships
with these ombudsmen, so
to speak, these people
on our campuses who
interact direct with students
and letting me know about the
resources that were available
and I was able to get
the support I needed.
And I think, in many ways the--
it starts with and I think most
of the panelist here would
probably agree but it starts
and ends with relationships.
If you don't have relationships
with students in the institution
or you don't have relationship
with people in the community
or you're not able to
build solid relationships
with each other.
You're not going to
get good work done.
And so I think it's
beginning to focus on--
so we want to get
through stigma,
you got to start building
relationships with those who are
in need, but having the
mechanisms to do that
and be able to scale up the
systems that are discovered
through those processes.
>> Our next question
will be in Spanish.
So our translator will
read that one for us.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> So I will try to translate,
interpret the question
into English and
[foreign language].
How has modernizationing
[phonetic] Oaxaca affected the
indigenous communities,
not only in the harvesting,
but also in natural
remedies for midwives?
Do you think that natural
remedies are being lost?
And also, how does food in
Oaxaca help not only children
and youth, but all the people?
[ Foreign Language ]
So, you know-- Can you hear me?
OK. So, when we get here, we--
the changes are not
only in food,
but also for example
in home remedies.
So it's important to try to
keep those whole remedies,
to try to get the
ingredients, but also to learn
about the local remedies
like Tylenol.
[ Foreign Language ]
So, one thing that we do in our
centers to educate the parents
about healthcare and well-being
and so we tell them sometimes
that there could be some
danger in some home remedies
and to be careful what they
give to their children.
[ Foreign Language ]
So, we also try to
teach them that it's OK
to use these home remedies,
but also to take their children
to the doctor to make sure
that our care doesn't affect
the heath of our children.
[ Foreign Language ]
So we try to teach them,
but also the ultimate
decision is on the parents.
Am I going to give
them a kamomile tea
or am I going to
give them a syrup.
So it's up to each
family at a point.
>> Thank you.
The next question is how come
a hamburger and fries cost less
than a head of broccoli?
>> How can a what?
>> When-- Sorry, I'm going
to repeat that question.
How come a hamburger
and fries cost less
than a head of broccoli?
Melissa?
>> Sure. I'll do
my best with this.
So, the farm bill
fund subsidizes food
that makes that possible.
That is the shortest answer.
And so when Kathy asked,
what are the policy that need
to change, and I
say all of them.
It's because how are we
funding corn syrup, hamburgers,
French fries, the oil that
goes into French fries,
all of those things and then
an organic farmer can't get
a subsidy.
and it comes from those
federal policies and a lot
of people aren't voting.
Let me speak about
that just for a second.
So I don't know if all of you
voted in the last selection
or in the midterm selections,
but if you didn't and you can,
please do and please
vote for the policies
that will change that.
>> The next question, also
on the international policy,
is NAFTA is an example of a
financial incentive to divest
of local food independence.
Similar financial trends
are well established
in the first world countries
and in university food systems.
Are there financial
incentives or economic models
that could work the other
way other than patches
such as charitable
food handouts?
>> You know, I think it's
the million dollar question.
Really, what I hear in that
question is what can we do
to shift our local foods-- ship
to a local food system, right?
I mean, that's fundamentally
what it's about.
And often what you will
find since I grow food
in the community and we have a
community supportive agriculture
program, we have been wrestling
with this for quite sometime.
What I find is that institutions
like UC Santa Barbara, UCLA,
UC Berkeley, et cetera.
LAUSD, et cetera, they all
have issues with scale, right?
So to feed 750,000 students
in LAUSD, you have to be able
to source in that food each
day to do that and it has to be
at such a cost that allows
you to meet the needs
of all those students,
same thing here
at these institutions.
And so in Los Angeles, the LA
Food Policy Councilor proposed
and they called the Good
Food Purchasing Pledge
which commits these institutions
to purchasing from local growers
and local owners and
sourcing their food as much
as possible from our own region.
And I think those types of
activities have to occur
if we're going to shift
from these larger sort
of sociopolitical systems
that are destroying
in many ways our food system.
And yes I agree that we are--
we are incentivized to purchase
from other countries
and whatnot.
And we also have to
appreciate what that does
and how it also helps to lift.
It can contribute too,
but it can also lift
people out of poverty.
So I think it's about sort
of taking a step back,
looking at the systems approach
or taking a systems approach
to understanding scale and then
figuring out how we're going
to re-localize our food
systems if we're actually going
to achieve equity and
close those disparities.
>> Just to add.
I think most of you
probably or know
about the Real Food Challenge
that the [inaudible],
but I know there's
workshops going on
and so it's been an effort
by students in the UCs
to shift the food purchase
of the UC system, right,
so that's another example.
And-- Well, you know, I've
worked closely on this--
the Good Food Purchasing
Pledge in LA and wanting
to support a more local food
system it also have to be,
you know, I mean it's--
the reality is it is a global
food system and I, you know,
I personally don't want
to give up chocolate,
I'm sure people don't
want to give
up their coffee and tea, right?
So there's still going to be
some food that we're going
to have to trade for from
other countries and we need
to make sure that that trade
is fair for those farmers
and farm workers
and other producers
in the other countries.
>> Well, a huge thank
you to our panelist.
I know I've learned
so much today.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]